je m'appelle buck j'ai grandi dans une
famille normale c'est pour les choquer
que tu fais ce que j'ai envie de choquer
c'est la société sas et frais je pense
qu'on peut cartonner non je te présente
andré avec qui tu vas travailler fait
plaisir de voir un petit corps soit pas
trop tard mais a changé étudiants
sociaux le jour acteur porno la nuit je
mens
tu te caches derrière l'arc et tu
touchant les matins vous embrassez vous
vous touchez naturel voilà naturel si tu
veux vraiment lutté et faire changer les
choses bien faire sauter des antennes
relais avec nous tu vas voir ce que
c'est que me dit tu es tu le laisse
faire ça toi ni majeur je vais pas le
séquestrer
[Musique]